let's go to William in Vegas, so William in
Las Vegas, Nevada, you're on the air.
William in Las Vegas, Nevada, please on mute
yourself, and then you'll be able to talk
to me.
All right, no, William in Vegas, they're very,
very interesting.
Let's go to Joe Joe in either Austin or Australia.
I just see this as a U.S.
Is it Austin, Texas or Australia?
No, boy.
Austin slash Australia, you're on the air.
No dice there, let's try Jason from Montreal,
you were on the air.
Hello, David, how are you doing today?
Good, how are you doing?
Pretty good.
So I've been a fan for multiple years.
I love your show.
You've been doing a wonderful job at covering
everything in US politics here.
Thank you.
My go to show pleasure.
I just wanted to make a few points here, basically.
So Republicans say they're pro-life, basically,
but they're anti universal health care and
they're living wage.
Anti Maspero were anti climate change.
So basically they they're against taking any
action to sustain our planet.
Pusser current generation.
So other than banning abortion for you, forgetting
that there are you want to ban abortion?
Yeah, definitely.
So I always thought it wouldn't be wouldn't
it be easier for Democrats to show how they're
more pro-life than Republicans by saying how
they're easier, healthier for easier access
to higher paying jobs, reducing massive, massive
wage disparity and conserving existing life?
The same could be applied with Universal with
Jubei, basically.
So, I mean, it seems like an easy point to
be arguing in U.S. politics, to be honest.
But you are, as you know, one, so many Democrats
are correct.
You're one hundred and ten percent correct.
And it just has not worked.
Now, whether it hasn't worked because Democrats
are terrible at messaging or it hasn't worked
because it's not as pithy.
But Republicans George Lakoff has written
about this a lot.
Republicans have been winning the messaging
war.
You are completely right.
What is pro-life about a Republican platform?
Pro-life just means anti-abortion.
But in terms of extending and improving life
on the planet, it is it is not I don't even
want to make it about party.
It is not the right that is for those things.
You're completely right.
And due to a combination of Republicans getting
get it being early to the game of the messaging
and Democrats being terrible at messaging,
it's it's proven more difficult than what
you're suggesting.
But you're completely correct.
Definitely, and I just wanted to make another
point here, basically, so my girlfriend, about
two summers ago, I got got pneumonia basically
in the middle of summer.
She could barely walk without being out of
breath.
Yeah, she's had respiratory issues ever since
she was born.
So we managed to get to a hospital.
I just plugged into a ventilator on and off
for about three hours.
And we left basically with a prescription
for additional pumps and a temporary one costing
about 80 dollars Canadian, which is absolutely
nothing.
So without, of course, any out-of-pocket costs,
I can't imagine how much this would have cost
in the US, basically.
So you don't want to know.
You don't want to know.
It would have been certainly thousands and
thousands of dollars.
Definitely.
It's really scary.
Well, thank you very much, David, for taking
my call.
I really appreciate it.
And I a wonderful day.
My pleasure.
Great to hear from you.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up, because
I'm going right back to the viewer and listener
calls right after this short break.